a few weeks ago Ricky Gervais is was on
our program and he talked about a new
app that he created called just sayin
and Ricky announced a stand-up comedy
contest where the winner gets to perform
stand-up right here on our show the
Conan show well all you have to do is
use the just say an app to record and
upload your three-minute comedy routine
and then Ricky will judge all the
entrance and he will pick a winner which
is pretty cool and then they come on the
show well now here with an update on how
the contest is going live via satellite
video this is very cool we can do this
live is mr. Ricky Gervais
I hope you're not trying to pretend this
is live by the way if this was live it
would be very late in England and this
isn't worth staying up for I'm being
honest so I recorded this earlier and
just posted the tape off to you I don't
even know if you've got it doesn't
matter yeah the competition I've been
going through all the submissions pour
which is good news for anyone I was and
ended yet nothing to beep so come on get
your submissions in win a spot on
Conan's show yeah I know but everyone's
got to start somewhere yeah so send his
submissions it's so easy to use just
download a joke or you know a minute of
your stand-up and win a three-minute
spot on Conan's show and don't be afraid
to use the video for silly we want to
see what you look like
you could get your own show from this if
Conan's got his own show literally
anyone can get their own show
on TV so what are you waiting for tell
them the details Conan I can't be
bothered
[Applause]
he's the best now to enter Ricky's just
saying stand up contest go to just
saying app.com for official rules and
Tails to be cool
[Applause]